so drinking likely origin within an hour
quite easily
[Music]
when was the first time you used drugs
or drink
I was almost 18 in Barnsley and I took
cooking which at the time she got quiet
enough mordrem to be taken thankfully I
had years off it in between and but up
until November the second 2018 so just
before Christmas like that's when I went
into rehab
and and I took pretty much drugs from
the age of 17 up until that point so
I've got 10 12 years full on probably
about yourself I'd say got a grip of me
at if that's when I'll static that was
18 years ago I was only drinking lager
to that with but then I hit a snag
drinking the gin and that was neat yeah
so drinking likely origin within an hour
quite easily
[Music]
and what was your lowest moment that's a
good one
well I tried to commit suicide in my car
I put the holes piping into the exhaust
pretty for the window and then all
families they're pleased about the
pulled up and dragged me off the cap
that was a large point my career kept me
clean during the week but not at the
weekend and but then when I had another
job I had no career I didn't have
anything really to get up for anymore
and then I went from being quite popular
in ever-larger
friends so just being sat in my car
I just wishing that I've just taken of a
line in it kill me unless you're
actually in it it's very hard for
somebody to to help you how did your
addiction affect your family at the
Sarah not so much not so much because I
could control it
and I was a secret drinker off so I
thought but turned out everybody didn't
know I used to be really outgoing I used
to be how every night been the pool team
gone wrong with visit families and I
became unsociable I think that's where
people sad to say why are you coming
because I have a will mmm 20 cans for
even got that I stopped getting invited
in there
the addiction states will affect me job
I may have a Nocturn you know I was
almost think of an excuse I went as far
as two girls there like orange peel Mei
and say I've got conjunctivitis I'll
have to go on you know I mean just to
get that drink my wife left me I've got
her now - you're old are now the number
onto me she realized when she was I'd
say I'd say about eight or nine
that our diet is improper ketamine and
it was like my main sort of poison I've
always lived quite an active lifestyle
I've always to applying laws of stuff
hobbies and sofa and joy and I kind of
stopped doing the things that made me
happy and family was the main thing I'm
always really close to my family and I
just stopped stopped ringing them
stopped answering the call Stokes was
first and foremost and then it was make
time for my girlfriend or my nephew or
my mom or my brothers and sister or
whatever it was but after a point they
kindly give up on you as well how did
your addiction affect your love life
apart from the obviously physical side
of it as well I was in too much pain to
ever kind of have sex or anything like
that I it's that lost self esteem myself
mmm I couldn't get aroused until I had a
skinful but obviously now looking back
and thinking who wants to sleep with
somebody was you that rectal yeah it
wasn't me
describe the feeling you had whilst
using and in the beginning about the
honeymoon period which probably lasted
for about four or five years and [ __ ]
love I love taking drugs I take it and
then I'd like literally pass out and get
carried out of a nightclub or have no
actual racking I would not have known
what I did for the past hour or two
referred to as a cat hole so you'd go
into our K hole or of a nickname just
got and you'd literally look like a
zombie and you just be like little and
you'd do the weird things where your
hands and your legs and just not give a
[ __ ] about anything
keep kind of like a comfort blanket this
is the best way it's like you're wrapped
in cotton wool
but I'd said for the last five or six
years it hasn't been enjoyable at all
yeah we used to go in the same pubs
drinking again hammered so we knew
everybody so upstairs was it was quite
high and how much we may ask for out of
it going pulling beds and yeah hey I
just wrapped on it it's just such a
phenomenal from growing for me loving it
so because you're enjoying it you kind
of don't want to stop but then when you
realize that you need to stop it's
impossible to stop it used to shut my
head up so like I couldn't function
until I had it and then I'd be arrested
for about 30 seconds I'm a bluff okay I
just hated it I pushed my daughter where
we did everything to happen some
addiction kicked in football you name it
we mean air was best bodies we did
everything together because I couldn't
let her see me her dad as I was I said
put covers over the mirrors just so I
couldn't see my reflection
because I hated myself that much after
adding shroud I said I actually wanted
to died from it did your friends and
family try to intervene and my friends
no because I pushed them away my father
he tried to intervene but in Mayas wrong
way
screaming him for saying man up man up I
can't just stop wow that's amethyst if I
just stopped I'd be dead
cuz your book because the in my own
house drinking my mom said you've always
got come near on girls
so in that way but it was only months
later that she actually passed away and
horrible simple fortunately she dad for
so the actual Mets are going so my
family never stopped me my friends
didn't stop me and so it's difficult
it's alright oh yeah
the only real true reason is because I
didn't like myself what motivated you to
go into recovery
my mum being the main thing and my
family and my ex relationship because I
realized how much I affected them and I
thought this isn't this isn't me your
mom never raised me to be like that's
rad stopping for my wife to save me
Marie is wrong if you have dreads from
your daughter that's I tried to stop for
me job
I couldn't sell for anything in somebody
yeah McCambridge them he said to me why
don't you think he deserved to be
athlete and that's me I couldn't answer
mean it was days and was just going on
we hadn't thought oh yeah I do deserve
to be happy and I said I was talking
some the next week and he said that's
all you can do her how will you become
happy I said I've got kicked this I and
that was a moment once you're happy for
yourself the rest will follow
what's the common misconception of
addiction nobody wants to be and have it
and most people get into addiction to
block things out to have fun things I
think everybody assumes that if you're
an addict they I even saying it but
you're homeless and you weren't around
are you stealing
you're already marginalized as it is
being an addict so when you're already
in that little bracket and then people
are sort of keeping your arms distance
even more it actually makes the problem
worse especially for the last six months
of fight before went into rehab
adil it should be up scanning Facebook
to see which drug dealers awake or where
I can go and get drugs
my first week was was hell the first few
months of being clean as hell I suffered
in crowds I suffered with so I social
anxiety being in being open spaces that
must be different through withdrawal
from alcohol and there's no withdrawal
from ketamine back in this way there is
so what's up alcohols out the system and
like a saucer as well like many people
in addiction like myself after a day I
was just I was wake up fresh Valis
appetite back no up getting invited to
all about their great usual things the
barbecues the weddings all the things
the whole things are want and now I can
go there with a sober face
why do you want to tell your story
I need reminding of how bad he actually
was because some days I don't think this
has been a bottomless this had been so
easy this recover lacked alcohol his
clusters okay it sold everywhere you can
get cheap sad as it will get you
eventually I don't think enough is
spoken about in terms of addiction even
just someone to speak to because they
can tell me about how much they're using
and what it is that they're doing and
everything else that comes with it like
that I psychologically and I can relate
to that I'm on the floor and I'll gain
Texas every single night or people a lot
of sound well I'm on the floor I do
actually say anything cuz I remember
what housing diction I just want to be
had because sometimes they're another
unset I can't get from Hanson the only
they know the answer I don't give him
advice and then to be honest he's no
better feeling than somebody said I
didn't drink vehicle yeah and I said no
he didn't drink yourself you wouldn't
pick the drink up as long as I can
remain completely abstinent then I think
everything else kind of falls into place
I kindly just do figures that I enjoy
and some things I don't enjoy as well
and but I need to do it to keep me clean
and to keep me to keep me aware and keep
me alert about around about the dangers
of falling back into addiction like I
feel more comfortable in myself whereas
before I just I hate feeling normal see
it is scary thinking life life without
your addiction it is terrifying founded
yourself again and I'm not controlled by
addiction any more inches which is key
we both got choices now yeah happy where
before in addiction you've got no choice
[Music]
you